some of you already there which is
fantastic you didn't take the long way
around which is great if I wanted to
take the long way around I would write
everything that I did for a but instead
of twos you're gonna replace them all
with sevens and it's literally identical
but what I can do is say hold on I I
don't have to give the long way around
I can recognize how a chain rule works
right you differentiate at the inside
then you differentiate the outside let
me rehearse it for you right what is the
inside function in this case it's that
7x right there right and we know what
the derivative of 7x is it's just seven
very good so I'll write that down to
review the inside done then I think
about the derivative of the outside what
is the outside function in this case
it's e to the power of thing right
what have we established happens when
you differentiate e to the power of a
thing no change at all right so that e
to the power of a theme becomes e to the
power of that thing and you're done
okay inside/outside finished okay have a
look over at Part II can you have a go
at party for me think again what's the
inside function in this case it's the 5x
so when you differentiate that you just
get five very good and then you look at
the outside function ah now this pesky
minus sign is hanging around right so
it's like not exactly this right so let
me remind you just come back to this guy
do you react square we know what it is
right what's the derivative of negative
x squared what effect is that minus sign
have
yeah you kind of just like I think most
of us kind of just ignore it for a
second right we just ignore it we're
like I know what the other Biddy is the
important part and then we just put that
minus sign back right so I should be
getting this there's that function it
didn't really change I wouldn't really
write out like this finally though it's
weed down at five that - in there I'm
gonna write it like so okay
all right now this time I actually
skipped over D which is what I wanted to
look at I want you to think about it
without writing anything down I just
want you to think about what is it doing
right I have a look at the function
right
it says e I'll write it down but we
don't need to actually write anything
for these so just wants to think about
it
e to the minus X I want you to go all
the way back to when we were doing
functions and graphing and transforming
what graphs looked like what effect does
this have on our original function we
know what this guy looks like we graphed
it we saw it in desmos what difference
is that minus sign have hmm this really
makes you think okay here the minus X go
ahead pull open your desmos window again
before you put in this function I'd love
you to just hide the derivative again
the main reason I want you to hide that
derivative is so that you can think
so here this is my e to the X right this
is e to the X I want us to think before
we sort of pop it in what's that um
what's that - something in effect have
on the derivative right so let's go
ahead up there at the top right see
where you've got your X power up there
right go ahead just be very careful with
your cursor and slap a minus sign in
front of that X what effects did that
have there was a and we've got to be
really careful our language here right
it's tempting to use a word like invert
right because invert sort of means like
what sort of flip around but in
mathematics like the inverse is a very
specific technical meaning which is not
this right remember we were talking
about Exponential's do have an inverse
what is it it's not another exponential
what's the inverse of an exponential
something we looked at our last week
starts with an owl it's a say it louder
- mo a logarithm right so that's the
inverse right this is not a log function
what is this let's be a weird it's it's
still an exponential but it's not
exponentially increasing it's not
exponentially growing we call this
exponentially decreasing exponentially
decaying right so that word decay if it
rings any bells from chemistry students
write radioactive decay looks like this
right it starts off real fast and then
as you have less and less radioactive
stuff it decays slower and slower and
slower
that's why half-lives are important
right okay what difference is is gonna
make to the derivative have a think when
we had a look at our original function
I'm just gonna put it back
this guy was increasing right you told
me it was always increasing but now I've
flipped it around what can you tell me
about it out it's always decreasing it's
always like going down right and it
never never turns around
so therefore where should you expect its
derivative to be
it's always gonna be on the negative
side I asked you to hide that derivative
can you put it back now right there it
is down the bottom here see nuts you're
like oh this is symmetry there the
derivative is always negative but it
gets less and less negative as you go
does that make sense okay so now let's
hide this
now you can in your books let's think
about this right so in your books come
back to writing this down
that's going here if I want to
differentiate this it's still the same
idea with chain rule
what is the inside function in this case
it's that negative x very good there it
is right there so what's its derivative
just that guy's derivative it's minus
one isn't it I just like this one was
five and this one was two and this one
was seven so in this case it's minus one
there's the inside function done and
then what's the derivative of the
outside part it's e to the power of a
thing so what happens to that same
nothing happens right so I'm just gonna
write that e to the power of whatever
was there before okay and please notice
that by the way it is e to power of
whatever was there before whether it's a
minus X or 5x or 7x or 2x that's what it
carries along right so I'll just tidy
that up like so you can see the reason
why we're down below the x-axis is will
point out is cuz of that minus sign out
the front okay